I can't even when she was like this big
wrinkle in her liver
[Music]
I think this is gonna be awkward it's
kind of a lot of pressure I think this
is gonna feel so right nothing's weird
to me
we assume you know what to do ready
write this let's go
[Music]
I oh my god your nose I look like a doe
first that's really weird-looking no I
don't like it I'm gonna watch it
so like I've really seen us kiss before
anyway her beanie and she looks like a
smurf I look like a smurf I did get a
pic junk of you're under gum oh that's
gross
okay I'm gonna bite her lip off she's
not having it cool I had like 5 Chin's
looks like I'm giving you CPR or
something
cuz now I look at okay it's just right
it's like a baby as I said it's not as
grotesque because my hair is kind of
like blowing in the wind and you got
your hand on my face that's cute see I
told you I think it does look like a
movie I see some chemistry there ha ha
ha so nice when it's just like yeah this
is like slow-mo kissing is beautiful oh
we look adorable thank you for that
you're welcome
[Music]
Wow I really have no chin either it's
just like Hello
that's so sweet you would kiss fat